I've been working with the fies from the
last 12 years last year I took a course
from the simply land and I got promoted
twice hi I am Rajesh Singh I am a
husband a father of two beautiful
daughters and an I.T professional Living
in America I moved to California six
years back for an AWS project at my
country in 2020 FIS decided to start a
five-year Project based on cloud which
was not there before at that time I was
working as a technical architect want to
explore more opportunities within my
company and I thought upskilling would
help me to get a promotion I decided to
go for the cloud architect Master scores
from Simply learn because I have always
been interested in Cloud technology
this technology has evolved over time
now it is providing high performance
application which are more reliable
I really like the online course that it
was convenient the course was
comprehensive and including modules like
AWS Azure and Google cloud while
covering the basics of the club after
the course I got promoted twice first to
the post of senior architect and then to
the senior development manager at my
company with the 30 person salary height
this course also helped me grow my
network I understand technicalities and
have better discussion with my peers
Living in America is a dream for many it
was my dream too I have now adjusted to
the American lifestyle I'm mostly
working but in my free time I like to
play Frisbee with my daughters learning
is lifelong every day is a new day and
we should learn something new everyday
this platform like civilians are really
good Focus